young welcome to a new video against
chest Dennis from Denmark yes I'm right
I'm so confused with those some
Scandinavian flags okay the bull go
again yeah I'd like to practice some of
those lines that i have in the book hmm
and yeah do I go to c 6 this is actually
a transposition to the to the new zone
not sure yeah this is a transposition
now to the Queen see two nums Oh Indian
the so-called Zurich variation from
Zurich Switzerland Switzerland and
Switzerland it's not Switzerland
Switzerland okay should I go a4 or does
he have C and C 5 is the principal
problem with a form and I'm not sure
that this is one of the positions where
you can play it
otherwise a for a desirable move of
course i'm setting up 57 setting up this
bind on down the queenside
97 text takes Bishop before whom don't
even have b6 available maybe this one
yeah a4 was maybe a tad too ambitious
it's not necessary to to do that
yeah that's a week it's a week Queen
side Queen to Queen 267 some claim as
some a big threat night a six can be
just a no wait it's not so easy night a
six leave it takes on a4ai can take
before word queen before
yeah this is really awful
hmm maybe something like this it's
looking like complete crap though I
really bungled this up maybe this is not
so bad actually I mean it it looks like
what but maybe it's not entirely
hopeless
they actually believe he can if
everything else fails you can just take
this piece on a six and play Queen c7
with some but quite a nice position and
this is love them probably not the best
move
okay don't mind that so much I get them
get to see 5 and I'm not busted
immediately then when I'm okay not a c5
and b6 or something it's not not a
problem I can take a form I've got 95
the attack attack's Queen and Bishop
that's all kinds of pieces saying some
you cannot okay and if i take with the
rook now let's do that first and think
later
yeah maybe maybe it's playable on
deserve some should be five yeah it's
probably okay and now i can play Queen
system not stupid yeah but that's a it's
not clear that I could could do anything
against this hmm
yeah just be seven just to be seven ok
can I cover can I just do this but he's
got done Queen to UM be seven hmm maybe
just back
it's really a super ugly chest
I'm not seeing at the moment how I'm
losing immediately they are probably
enough long-term issues but I don't see
him a direct way to to punish me for all
this nonsense it's nicely covered maybe
I can even not get get in oops come on
get in this irritate them now irritated
bishop age 39 t 33 and so on there are
some ideas mmm sick now probably not
young but ok let's try to irritate him
ok if this didn't really work out so
just to see eight come on let's push f5
this is some strategically desirable
anyway fo
don't know
ah come on don't just take it huh Vic
no it's very highly solid really
check time warning check
it's probably a draw not anymore hi wow
wow just damn I'm I was what I wanted
just one second da and more time Amy
managed to grab this okay yeah I somehow
slipped here with my finger or something
ah ok yeah it was a really awful defense
all the time yeah yeah well I still try
to make moves everything of course if i
go and pretty move mode with 15 against
eight I win this in my sleep but um it's
it's still um it's still a game and try
to take the things that he's offering me
but that was some it was some just a
slip at the end and the opening I should
I shouldn't play for really I knew that
this is a tricky tricky move and this is
really wow this is this problem of
before we can to brush up on before
leads to UM to big problems hope like
yeah thanks for watching